president Trump's former campaign
chairman Paul Manafort will be back in
court this morning for the second day of
his high-stakes criminal trial now this
is the first trial related to the
special counsels Russia investigation
yesterday the judge moved quickly
through jury selection opening
statements and the first witness
testimony Paula Reid is outside the
Alexandria Virginia courthouse Paula
good morning tell us what happens today
good morning Nora that's right the judge
overseeing this case he is known as the
rocket docket for how quickly he moves
through cases and yesterday prosecutors
told the jury that Manafort failed to
disclose tens of millions of dollars
that he earned for lobbying on behalf of
Ukrainian politicians they allege he
then laundered that money through these
little havoc purchases they described a
twenty-one thousand dollar watch a
fifteen thousand dollar jacket made from
ostrich and an estimated two million
dollar home just down the street from
here a mana fort is of course a longtime
Republican political operative but he's
not charged with anything related to
President Trump or the campaign Manaf
orts lawyers they argue that it was mana
forts one-time business associate and
former deputy trunk campaign chairman
richard gates who failed to disclose all
of their earnings to the IRS
now Gates is cooperating with the
special counsel he is expected to
testify against manna fort during this
trial and at any moment during these
proceedings manna fort can still agree
to plead guilty and try to cooperate
with special counsel also at any point
during these proceedings
the president could preemptively
pardoned him Alex
Paula thank you